hello mr. Sean Plott fans and I don't
know if Sean is here now but thank you
for the the heads up of this stream
let's go
III is gonna be what here right now be
for is being prepared I'm gonna go with
this and try and show hopefully that a
three turns out to be a drawback let's
see about that I'm gonna go with B six
yeah why not he's six and then this has
to be a bit uncomfortable wouldn't you
think or would you think otherwise is
that really uncomfortable we dude this
hmm yeah I could do that Knight to e7 I
do not want to be cautious of Knight b5
exploiting this hole on d6 but I just I
win that Bishop if that comes here but
it's it definitely has my attention
right now and actually if I am NOT
careful after night here Knight here is
a reasonable move I can already tip the
king ninety-seven Knight b5 Bishop takes
Bishop Knight check King here Queen
takes f7 TKO so what I'm getting at is
let's not and say we did on that one but
rather hit this queen first force her to
go back home is she too good for her own
you might be asking just as mr. happy
gilmore
so 97 Queen has to go back and this has
to be a bit uncomfortable does it not
mmm we're gonna still have this night
coming here hitting this guy three times
this is different interesting well
here's the big bad plan and it involves
actually maintaining my night on this
square so in response to the night here
I don't take definitely not I support
the night but I'm wondering should I
support it right now or just develop
first I'm gonna develop first I don't
like the idea of actually playing here
and allowing for Knight d5 right away I
think eventually I'll be I could do that
by force B having to play this a five
move to lend support to my my furthest
advanced piece right here the one that
is in White's territory on d4 but I I
don't want I want this night to go
elsewhere before I play e5 is what I'm
getting at um so know what okay now how
do you recapture I think with the bishop
if I do with the pond the night place
here I don't know if I really want to
make this weakening move so I'm not
gonna do that all the way huh you
kidding me this keeps showing up I know
it's okay actually Bishop takes Knight
here I could take the bishop and I could
take here with check but at the end of
it all I'm up a minor piece my king is
on Castle but so what this is a good
square so we're having this I can't
really maintain the bishop so let me
take it and there might be a check
thrown in but there's not so I have dark
square weaknesses but this Knight is
clearly out of place and right now I'm
looking to expand in the center and this
Bishop is gonna have a difficult life
ahead of it so and actually the night
because if I may get this structure in
what is that where's this night gonna go
let me do this first and then this or
this first if I do this then the Queen's
has to make a move where she's defending
that pond still I'm gonna do this I'm
liking my position now definitely liking
it
I've Queen here maybe I could do this I
don't know I really like this move
actually I think this is best even
though it gives this square - why
maybe the bishop move was not correct
maybe keeping my bishop still on its
home square going with c4 and if the
Queen was gonna try to blockade I could
play Knight f5 which will control that
d4 square but this is just dropping
isn't it actually it's not because the
rooks would just get played this pawn
would fall but now it's uh now it's a
big threat and I want to maintain this
structure this is a tough now the knight
is not protected the bishop is shut out
of the game and I guess we're gonna be
seeing Knight here pretty soon I mean
off for a queen exchange I think it's
not for Queen exchange why not and if
I'm to recapture how do I recapture with
which rook I might want to go with this
rook even though this would have no
moves to it if I go like this I'm
looking for a five most likely and let
me take the Queen and then react to this
threat so I'm still trying to work on
these guys right here being out of play
this one particular I guess there's a
way out chop chop and then pawn push
however I think that this becomes an
issue now because I get to double here I
get to use this as a pivot square and
when here I'm threatening this pawn this
Bishop actually cannot move it can't
move if it plays here the rook is
unprotected if it plays here in the rook
is unprotected so what's needed is well
there's no good solution for light as
far as I can tell right now no good
solution and I think I do something as
simple as a lot
what's the scoop here night here we
exchange nights I think I want to keep
my night around in fact what I'm
envisioning right now is a night getting
to this square so if I play Bishop up
Bishop here actually Bishop right here
is threatening to just double the rooks
and then win the bishop I can actually
do that afterwards though hang on this
is okay first force the rook here that
way when I play to f5 it's more forceful
this is an incredibly annoying pin I do
not know that there's a solution to it
my first thought is just that there
isn't this is too too cramping pins
Bishop way down on squares this is the
ideal type of structure so it may seem a
bit weird because of how often I'll
emphasize well if you only have one
Bishop remaining what do you want to
have happen you want to have your pawns
on dark and your Bishop you know is
going to be watching over the light
squares but not here okay I have too
much of a space advantage and this is
going to be a killer
I could actually I'm threatening to just
kill all the just capture on this square
a bunch of times and then at the end of
it all land a fork with my knight on c3
so that tricky Knight
this is the last piece that I needed to
get the last piece I needed to get
involved in order to break down team
white here I'm pretty sure what else I'm
not sure what else
my phone is typing my way here and I
know what they're saying here what are
they saying
they're gonna be letting their clock
tick don't tell me they're gonna oh
they're typing good game okay well how
do I keep things super simple let me
actually do this and then that pin is
still a big big issue okay we have
resignation at that point there was no
good solution that's kind of how it
works
so this was really interesting you had
me worried quite a bit with these
possible in between moves that night
coming to b5 exploiting my bishop being
unprotected on g7 interesting in the
Queen move as well so I wonder if
actually taking my knight is the right
idea I guess it's okay
this starts to be a problem though
actually because of how I could you know
I've parried any of those threats to you
know those tactical threats to my
unprotected bishop on g7 but beyond that
what what is there really to say so I
think there's a there's got to be an
improvement here because I think I'm
pretty sure it's safe to say right here
I'm gonna stand better even though I
have these weaknesses how can you really
take advantage of them I'm getting d5 in
I'm getting c4 in just two pawns one way
to view it is I have two points
constraining six both of your minor
pieces are negated just because of a d5
c4 structure so where's there an
improvement then if we're entering this
situation is it just going to turn out
that this turns out to be too powerful I
mean being able to centralize my knight
and then you having to get rid of it
because you know I what out what else is
there here
what about
how about something like rook here or no
no how about this hmm no that's not
working either huh I wonder if defending
the bishop and then playing your knight
here but this doesn't seem right
actually to allow the knight to sit in
the in the corner or in the center like
this in the corner in the center that
can't be right can it with tempo hitting
the Queen something does not feel right
right there
so yeah 94 so Queen f3 is maybe just not
a good idea right I mean I guess the
other thing I could do is try to go
after the LightSquared Bishop if I
really wanted to so something else
besides Queen f3 I guess night out
something is uh as natural as as night
here or maybe maybe capture here first
no although that's subjecting your
bishop to problems by my rook don't know
the Queen move definitely does seem off
not so sure or his could you actually go
with this instead of uh excuse me
instead of Knight c3
I wondered if c3 and then d4 is an idea
moving a lot of pawns but it comes with
the purpose a paries the threat against
the rook of course and also facilitates
a d4 expansion in the center that might
be interesting all right c3 if I ever
take you just take like this and then
you're still in a spot to get in d4 so
that is an interesting idea I think in
response to it I think I'll be playing
d5 I don't know that it's gonna get
pretty crazy it's worth a look though
that c3 move seems a bit awkward to have
throw throw a piece right into a pin
there were some tactics I was again
having to worry about but okay let's
close out of this one and get another
one fired up here